hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute was
orientalisch ist aber auch nicht so
wirklich denn diesen kuchen oder diese
torte können ganz viele nachmachen ob
jetzt muslimischen glaubens seien oder
nicht ich persönlich habe es jetzt
gemacht für ist opferfest was bald
ansteht also auf türkisch kuban bei
damme und auf arabisch hamza genau und
davide traditionellen schaf geschlachtet
und hat merck wir machen heute eine
richtig leckere schafft orte die sieht
nicht nur richtig süß putzig aus an die
schmeckt auch richtig lecker
im inneren befindet sich angeblich
kuchen dazu setze ich euch gleich noch
ein bisschen was dann haben wir aus rom
ein leckeres forsting und die leckeren
marshmallows wir gehen jetzt direkt über
zu den zutaten für den rückblick kuchen
wir benötigen geraspelte möhren außerdem
gemahlene mandeln walnüsse die habe ich
auf gehackt zucker backpulver und
vanillezucker als erstes bereit mit den
leckeren saftigen kuchen vor und dafür
gehen wir die eier zusammen mit dem
zucker und dem vanillezucker in die
küchenmaschine und schlagen das fünf
minuten lang richtig dick cremig falls
ihr den handbohrer verwendet dann
braucht also ungefähr acht minuten und
ich schwöre das sind vier eier gewesen
das sieht aus wie fünf eier ich weiß
nicht warum ich glaube ich hatte zwei
dort drin
[Musik]
so nach fünf minuten hatte eine richtig
schöne die cremige masse erhalten und
jetzt gehen wir einfach nur alle anderen
zutaten mit hinein und rühren dass mit
unserem teigs aber gut unter
[Musik]
übrigens hat meine mutter diesen kuchen
früher immer gemacht hat sich noch ganz
jung war
dann dachte ich nur so gesund möhren
drin
und dann habe ich nie davon gegessen und
meine schwester hat immer richtig
reingehauen und jetzt denke ich nur so
ernsthaft der ist so lecker ich hätte
damals schon erkennen müssen wie lecker
und saftig dieser kuchen ist und jetzt
gebe ich noch die wahlliste mit rein
die sind optional aber dann habt ihr
später noch so einen richtig leckeren
bis mit drin
so der teig ist fertig den ofen habe ich
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze
vorgeheizt jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere
springform die habe ich hier unten mit
backpapier ausgelegte die seiten nicht
fetten dass es gar nicht nötig und jetzt
einfach den teig einfüllen und backen
[Musik]
so der teig gesetzt drin und ich habe
heute eine kleinere springform gewählt
22 zentimeter im durchmesser
denn ich möchte später sondern kriegt so
eine richtig kleine süße torte haben und
ihr könnt natürlich auch gern ein
bisschen größer backen dann verringert
sich aber auch die backzeit weil der
teig da nicht so hoch wird so ganze 35
minuten hatte zwei jahre gedauert macht
einfach die stäbchen probe einfach steht
den rein halten wenn es trocken wieder
rauskommt dann ist der kuchen komplett
durch ich habe mir schon etwas auskühlen
lassen auf der form befreit aber da ist
noch ein bisschen lauwarm und bevor wir
die creme darauf verteilen muss er
komplett auskühlen
ihr könnt damit es nicht ganz trocken
wird hier einen trick anwenden das mache
ich mal ganz gerne und zwar nehme ich
einfach feuchtes küchenpapier und gibt
auf einmal so drüber und dann könnt ihr
das auch problemlos in den kühlschrank
legen während unser leckerer kuchen
jetzt grad abkühlt nutzen wir die
zwischenzeit und bereiten schon mal die
creme form und dafür benötigen wir
folgende zutaten kalte schlagsahne
außerdem mascarpone dies ebenfalls total
kalt sahne steif und vanillezucker
unsere krähen bereite ich jetzt hier in
der küchenmaschine zu ihr könnt auch ihr
handrührgerät verwenden das ist gar kein
problem
jetzt gebe ich zu aller erst mals capone
sahne und zucker rein und dann wird das
ganze ganz kurz miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
auf niedrigster stufe lasse ich jetzt
mach capone und sahne miteinander
verbinden nur ein paar sekunden lang und
dann gehen wir seine streifen mit dazu
und schlangen dass auf höchster stufe
komplett steif
[Musik]
so nach nur eineinhalb minuten ist unser
themen fertig und die gebe ich jetzt bis
zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank
so jetzt kann der spaß digital beginn
darauf freue ich mich schon den ganzen
tag wie dekoriert die torte mein boden
ist komplett ausgekühlt die creme habe
ich jetzt gerade frisch aus dem
kühlschrank dann wurde ich zeige euch
jetzt die weiteren zutaten für unsere
deko das ist einmal nuss nougat creme
ich habe jetzt nur teller genommen die
habe ich mir in einen spritzbeutel
gefüllt und vorne habe ich mir kleine
loch thüle
falls ihr keine loch tolle da hab gar
kein problem schneidet dann vorne
einfach nur eine ganz kleine spitze ab
dann habt ihr den gleichen effekt
außerdem brauchen wir das ist das
allerwichtigste marshmallows ich habe
jetzt hier weiße und rosanna der jetzt
beim türken gefunden also einen
türkischen supermarkt die sind schon so
also die marke kürzlich zeigen dass es
keine produkte könnte ich mir so nicht
genau weiß welches ist es keine
produktion habe ich endlich selber
verkauft aber ihr habt ihr weiß und rosa
das ist ganz gut denn wir brauchen zwar
ganz viele weiße aber gleich auch noch
zwei euro sondern es zeige ich euch
nachher und weil sie so zu lang sind
werden die in der mitte noch einmal
durchschneiden die weißen
und jetzt schneide ich den boden noch
einmal schön gerade damit eine gerade
oberfläche haben leider passiert mir das
auch manchmal dass der boden in der
mitte einsehen das kann man halt nicht
immer vermeiden
aber das ist kein problem der ist hoch
genug und das ist überhaupt kein problem
wenn ich da jetzt ein bisschen von
abschneide als nächstes gibt ihr euch
euren kuchen schon mal auf eure wunsch
der platte the pc so eine tiefe genommen
ihr könnt auch einen teller neben der
kuchen ist er klein genug und jetzt
gehen wir unsere creme drauf und
verstreichen die rundherum
[Musik]
sobald die torte dann rundherum mit der
creme verstrichen habt machen wir mit
den marshmallows weiter und die
marshmallows die dienen jetzt als
scharfes fällt und ich habe jetzt
halbiert weil die sonst einfach zu dick
wären erstens für die optik und zweitens
auch später beim essen und ist die
kollegen wir das ganze einfach daran
spart die ohren aus denn darlehen
begleichen sarault seines mal schneller
aber dann zeige ich euch noch ganz genau
wie ihr vorgehen müsse
[Musik]
für die ohren nehmen wir uns jetzt einen
rosa marshmallow und schneiden einmal
diagonal durch somit erhalten wir zwei
oben
die geben wir jetzt hier noch an die
seite und dann machen wir mit den weißen
so weiter und sparen hier nur die mitte
für das gesicht aus also ich finde das
gesicht ist schon ganz gut erkennbar man
hat das fell man hat die ohren jetzt
will nur noch augen nase und mund und
das zeichnen wird es in unserem stück
spieß einmal vor damit es später
leichter haben
[Musik]
und deckt den wir noch die nase da drauf
und fertig so meine lieben die schaffst
orte ist fertig und ich finde die
zuckersüß falls das ganze jetzt
nachmachen möchte schaut hier unten in
die infobox rein da stehen die genauen
mengenangaben und wenn ihr das ganze
nach macht dann bitte bitte schickt mir
eure fotos oder postet ihr auf instagram
mit dem hashtag ich s kitchen gerade bei
diesem rezept freue ich mich sehr auf
eur fotos genau wie bei allen anderen
rezepten falls sie mehr auf exakt noch
nicht folgt dann holt das jetzt ganz
schnell nach ansonsten könnte ich hier
gerne abonnieren wer einen deutschen
nach oben da lassen sich das wieder
gefallen hat und jetzt wünsche ich euch
ein gesegnetes opfer fest im kreise
ihrer liebsten kurban bayrami war der
kurs und haben sie auf arabisch genau
ich wünsche euch jetzt alles liebe und
bis zum nächsten mal auf die keys
kitchen
[Musik]